it appeared divisions between Iran and
Saudi Arabia were going to take a long
time to heal that was until Friday's
announcement in Beijing they are not
very interestingly we hope that this new
chapter will compensate for the
stagnation of relations that took place
these last seven years and also leads to
stability and Security in the region as
well as a development and Welfare of all
of his people
this marked the end of a seven-year
diplomatic Rift but rivalry between Iran
and Saudi Arabia stretches back for
decades and has roots in history
the two countries represent the
theological division between Islam's two
major branches Shia and Sunni
and since the Iranian Islamic revolution
in 1979 there have been several
diplomatic and security crises
Saudi Arabia supported Saddam Hussein's
invasion of Iran in 1980. seven years
later Iranian pilgrims clashed with
Saudi Security in Mecca leaving hundreds
dead on both sides in 2011 Riyadh sent
hundreds of troops and armored vehicles
into Bahrain to Quail and Iranian
bhaktia uprising
[Applause]
when Iran backs houthi Fighters rose up
against yemeni government Saudi Arabia
LED an air campaign to Austin
that proxy war still rages on today
Riyadh has also accused Iran of
interference in Iraq Syria and Lebanon
and stoking instability and sectarian
Bloodshed in those countries
Iran's nuclear program was another
concern Tehran insisted it was meant for
civilian purposes Saudi Arabia failed
Iran's hidden objective was to produce a
nuclear bomb both sides have interests
of their own the Iranian side wants to
try to bypass the international
isolation especially given that the
jcpoa The Joint comprehensive plan of
action looks unlikely now to be revived
and for Muhammad Salman he needs a
period of domestic calm while he focuses
on Vision 2030 which was announced in
2016 so we're now the halfway point and
he really needs to focus on delivering
tangible economic results for the Saudi
people with the new rapprochma the two
major regional economic and political
heavyweights could enter an era of peace
and stability this could include an end
to the war in Yemen and a viable
political and economic way out of the
impasse in Lebanon Muhammad Al Jazeera